[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Antoine Glaser on dit souvent la
politique africaine de la France
n'existe plus il y a plus de politique
africaine de la France mais c'était quoi
exactement la politique africaine de la
France ah bah il y a quand même une
politique africaine de la France des
indépendants de 1960 jusqu'à la chute du
mur de Berlin il y a eu une vraie
politique africaine qui était une
paillote historique je veux dire avec un
système intégré politique militaire
financier qu'on a appelé globalement la
France Afrique mais qui était vraiment
une politique qui correspondait à une
période historique c'était vraiment la
période de la guerre froide les propres
alliés de la France le sait gérer
l'ensemble de ces anciennes colonies à
sa guise en particulier toutes les
prébendes de l'uranium il faut quand
même se rappeler qu'en 62 la France a
été fait virer de l'Algérie donc à
retrouver les ressources pétrolières
dans ce Golf de Guinée du Gabon et du
Congo le Gabon l'appelait le pays pub
pétrole uranium et manganèse d'accord il
y a une pile atomique pour le d'uran et
donc c'était pour moi il y avait
vraiment une période historique c'est ça
le reste n'existe pas et la figure
centrale de tout ça c'était un petit
bonhomme qui s'appelle Jack focard qui
était un gaulliste de la première heure
qui il faut pas quand même oublier que
finalement c'est quand même l'Afrique
quand on partit aider ou qui a libéré la
France du nazisme donc c'était certain
que ce petit bonhomme qui avait géré
pendant très longtemps les services
secrets français à travers un organisme
peut-être baissera à partir fièrement de
Londres ce qui restait de de la France
libre était en Afrique et finalement ben
focard il s'est la reprise c'est
pantoufles à partir du moment où
finalement la la l'Afrique a libéré la
France donc il a repris dans les années
60 il a repris tous ses réseaux et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a eu tout ce côté
mystérieux parce que c'est vrai que
c'était d'abord
il sert appuyé sur les services secrets
français et c'était vraiment du
néocolonialisme à cette époque là
comment ça se passait
historique ça veut dire Jack focard on
avait été l'interviewé avec Steven Smith
à l'époque à luzar chez lui qui était
déjà très âgé parisienne dans le
Val-d'Oise et lui quand on lui demandait
mais alors pour vous la France Afrique
il dit oui il disait il est avec une
espèce de bonhomie disait ce qui est bon
pour la France et bon pour l'Afrique à
l'époque c'était vraiment les gens qui
ont cru à une communauté de destins
entre la France et l'Afrique c'est lui
voilà ça veut dire il verrouillait tout
il fallait vraiment que ça soit tous ces
pays vote comme un seul homme aux
Nations Unies et c'était vraiment une
sorte d'assimilationnisme de la entre la
France et l'Afrique ça veut dire c'était
vraiment une période où on considérait
que c'était une petite France en Afrique
Petite France en Afrique c'est-à-dire
que les gouvernements bien que après
l'indépendance ces gouvernements étaient
étroitement
assujetti finalement à ce que penser à
ce que voulait Paris il faut quand même
pas oublier que avant les indépendances
à certains nombre de présidents
africains avec des ministres vous faites
Boigny de Côte d'Ivoire au président
Léopold Sédar Senghor du Sénégal avait
été quand même ministre dans les
gouvernements français on oublie comment
le général il y a DESMA quand même du
Togo du Togo il a crapahuté avec l'armée
française non seulement en Indochine en
Algérie le celui qui est devenu
l'empereur Bokassa en Centrafrique avait
également été dans l'armée française il
y a du grand chef ça veut dire ces
petits plats ils étaient avec l'armée
française en train de tirer je viens sur
les Algériens ou en adochine etc donc on
oublie à quel point il y avait quand
même cette communauté qui était intégré
dans la dispositif français et alors
après donc vous dites à la chute du mur
de Berlin là ça commence à changer il y
a le discours de la Baule inspiré ou
écrit plus ou moins par Erik Orsenna
d'ailleurs en 19 91 et là ça commence à
changer et là il y a plus de politique
africaine c'est ça non moi je pense que
Eric Orsenna franchement il a écrit ça
sur un coin de table mais c'est pas ça
c'est simplement que un certain moment
donné à la chute du mur de Berlin tout
le monde regardait la réunification de
l'Allemagne mais la France ne voyait pas
du tout l'Afrique ce mondialisée c'est
ça le fond de la faire d'accord c'est
que finalement cette période historique
on va pas refaire l'histoire mais on
pourrait on aurait pu imaginer que le
président français avec ses pères
africains de cet ancien prix carré fasse
une grande réunion en disant pas un
petit texte de La Baule mais un grande
réunion en disant voilà l'Afrique ce
mondialyse ils font face à autre chose
etc et en fait la France c'est un peu
endormie un peu sur sa rente politique
économique dans cette région et n'a pas
vu l'Afrique ce mondialisée on a
l'impression que la France elle s'est
réveillé récemment disant mais comment
qu'est-ce qui se passe en Afrique et
autres mais en Afrique c'est mondialisée
dans les années 2000 ce sont d'abord les
Chinois qui ont vraiment réactivé
inhiber l'Afrique et on parle de la
Chine à frileux on a parlé de la Chine
Afrique et ensuite les propres
partenaires européens de la France je
veux dire on n'a pas vu non plus que
l'Allemagne est devenu le premier
exportateur européen vers l'Afrique on
n'a pas vu que les Italiens ils
reprenait la langue avec la Libye avec
tous les anciennes colonies les
Espagnols avec aussi le la vue comment
ils reconnaissent maintenant le Sahara
Occidental la marocanité sur le Sahara
Occidental on est dans des périodes
historiques et la France est vraiment
endormie dans son ancien prêt carré n'a
pas vu la mondialisation de l'Afrique et
elle n'a quand il y a eu le coup d'État
par exemple en 1999 en Côte d'Ivoire il
y avait la cohabitation en France
j'ose pas rien dit et Chirac président
de la République n'a rien dit non plus
c'est-à-dire qu'il s'est on a laissé
faire et là il y a une dérive justement
de la Côte d'Ivoire
a essayé de faire réagir même en cas de
cohabitation finalement c'était le coup
d'État du Père Noël en Côte d'Ivoire et
finalement depuis 16 réagir et à un
moment donné les conseillers africains
que ça soit de autant l'Elysée enfin
l'Élysée c'était du push mais un
cohabitation Premier ministre de Lionel
Jospin ils sont tous partis en vacances
et ils ont éteint leur portable ils ont
dit à Dupuis si vous arrivez à faire
bouger la CEDEAO la Communauté des États
d'Afrique de l'Ouest si vous avez des à
certains nombres de chefs d'État
africains qui veulent réagir et bon on
va on va on va on verra mais sinon ils
ont laissé tomber parce que c'était une
période de cohabitation alors il y a eu
des retours que ça soit au moment aussi
de la chute de Laurent Gbagbo en Côte
d'Ivoire
il y a eu des périodes où il y a eu des
retours ça veut dire où la France c'est
imposé militairement militaire mais je
veux dire globalement cette fin de
période était quand même une période une
seule période historique et donc en 2000
2007 donc on est au mois de juillet
juste après l'élection Nicolas Sarkozy
il va à Dakar reçue par le président
Abdoulaye Wade et il fait un discours
dans lequel il dit l'homme africain
n'est pas rentré dans l'histoire un
discours qui aurait été écrit et il a
été en partie par Henri Guaino et là ça
évidemment il y a la grande polémique
rupture même quasiment les Africains
absolument pas compris c'est vrai que
c'est affligeant parce que c'est une
méconnaissance de l'Afrique ça veut dire
j'ai jamais entendu jusqu'à ce jour un
président français dire il faut
apprendre de l'Afrique apprendre de la
feuille ce continent capsulant
incroyable à tous les points de vue pas
simplement pour ces matières premières
mais même c'est au niveau sociologique
on est son humanité et autres apprendre
de l'Afrique et là on voit bien que là
il y a une telle méconnaissance qu'on a
toujours l'impression qu'il y a la
métropole et le continent africain ça
veut dire c'est encore une une pensée
ancienne pas du tout une pensée moderne
ça veut dire c'est méconnaissance de
l'Afrique ça veut dire il faut que
l'Afrique domaine de la France et donc
ils sont pas assez rentrés dans
l'histoire il faut qu'il faut qu'il
revoit leur histoire de France en 2011
cette fois il y a les printemps arabes
qui commencent à enfin commence en
Tunisie mais il y a aussi un événement
qui va être tout à fait fondamental pour
l'avenir de l'Afrique c'est la chute de
Kadhafi et déjà ce pays qui n'était pas
vraiment un état constitué qui tenait
par un homme et ben va se déliter et là
ça va changer toute la face de l'Afrique
de l'Ouest au moins vous êtes d'accord
avec ça pour dire que ça ça a été un
élément capital de l'histoire de de
l'Afrique moderne la contemporaine
absolument je veux dire quand on voit
parce qu'il faut quand même s'appuyer si
moi je dis que c'était une erreur
fondamentale on dit ok il connaît pas
mais quand on voit quand même Barack
Obama est considère dans le livre qu'il
a écrit dans ses Mémoires qui considère
que c'est sa principale erreur de dans
sa politique des Affaires étrangères
c'est pas voilà
ils disent carrément ils ont fait un peu
entraîner par un peu ils sont entraînés
par les Français je vais dire c'est
certain que le même les Anglais ont
reconnu aussi que c'était quand même une
erreur fondamentale Joe Biden à l'époque
vice-président des États-Unis avait dit
il était contre cette intervention il
avait dit il faut pas y aller si on voit
pas à 10 ans en suite si on voit pas ce
qui va se passer après bon pour ceux qui
connaissent évidemment la région on
savait qu'il y avait un équilibre
précaire c'est vrai que Kadhafi c'est
vrai qu'il faisait les fins de moi des
chefs d'État de la région le grand frère
algérien c'était la sécurité ça allait
mal entre Algérie et Libye quand il dit
bien installé un consulat à Kidal au
nord du Mali ils Algériens étaient pas
contents mais il y avait une sorte
d'équilibre il y avait un équilibre
précaire alors après on peut raconter
effectivement sur le Roi des rois c'est
tout ce qu'elle est pas dire que Kadhafi
j'ai pas que c'est pas c'était pas
dictateur mais encore une fois c'était
pas faire des Occidentaux d'intervenir
sur ce continent alors que l'Union
africaine était contre tout le monde
était compte donc c'est pour ça que là
il y a vraiment c'était quelque chose
qui est fondamental c'est une armurerie
là la Libye est une armurerie assez
nouvelle et on voit bien qu'un ça nombre
de d'armements en particulier on a vu
comment les Touaregs étaient religion
islamiques de Kadhafi sont rentrés avec
armes et bagages au nord du Mali au
Niger les Nigériens ont su mieux gérer
le retour des Touaregs armés parce que
les ont beaucoup plus intégré dans
l'appareil d'État mais très franchement
ça a quand même déstabilisé en partie
tout cette région et les djihadistes du
GIA du groupe alislamique algérien ce
qui était en Algérie en ont profité pour
faire des alliances avec les Touaregs
qui rentraient de Libye et doux c'est là
où tout a commencé en fait
et là c'est là où bon ben on est
confronté à ce qu'on et bien une espèce
de tentative de constitution de Khalifa
ce qui est pas tout à fait vrai non plus
parce que ce sont des groupes qui les
uns les autres se combattent qui n'ont
pas tous les mêmes objectifs qui pour
beaucoup sont plus relèvent plus je
dirais de de la grande délinquance que
de la volonté de créer un État islamique
mais tout ça fait que la France va
intervient en 2013 avec François
Hollande ça deviendra la force barkhane
et finalement ça sera un échec avec ça
oui alors pas refaire l'histoire mais
c'est vrai que quand on parle de
djihadiste c'est vrai que c'est d'abord
avant tout quand même des groupes armés
qui ont des territoires c'est des c'est
vraiment les grandes caravanes et c'est
d'abord des trafics en tout genre c'est
une économie qui est informelle c'est
vraiment une période historique aussi
qui est se termine ça veut dire c'est
une période pour moi qui est poste
coloniale il y a depuis la Mauritanie
jusqu'au Soudan on voit que toute cette
période ils ont fait fuir il y a plus
d'Occidentaux dans toute cette région
suivie de regarder une carte du Quai
d'Orsay pour se rendre compte que tout
est en rouge y compris quasiment
jusqu'au Captain on n'a pas intérêt à y
aller quoi exactement et donc c'est vrai
que l'opération maintenant il y a une
sorte de consensus en disant que
d'intervenir avec l'opération Serval ça
avait peut-être un sens mais il aurait
fallu tout de suite une fois que les
libres les villes du Nord étaient
libérées qui est pas d'opération
barkhane qui était une opération
extérieure un peu à l'ancienne et en
fait c'est vrai que un peu ça sert cette
opération barkhane de cette présence de
l'armée française un peu à l'ancienne
servait déjà de cash misère à une
présence française globalement en
déshérence l'ensemble du continent il y
avait de moins en moins de français dans
les capitales on est depuis dans la
période post-coloniale où la France
avait une rente politique dans toute
cette région avec des chefs d'État amis
qui avaient été encore une fois bien sûr
dans tout le dispositif de la France en
Afrique je passe du coq à l'âne mais
quand vous allez à la au Muséum de
Bruxelles le Tervueren quand vous entrez
il y a écrit en gros c'est un socialiste
un sociologue belge il y a écrit le
passé tout passe sauf le passé qui passe
pas et là la France n'a pas tiré les
leçons de ce passé qui ne passait pas
alors il y en a beaucoup qui disent mais
en fait pour que la France garde une
bonne image ou pour qu'elle soit
acceptée là où elle est rejetée
aujourd'hui il faut le dire dans
certains pays d'Afrique il faut des
militariser et puis il faut revenir à
une espèce de partenariat ou de
coopération qui soit justement dénuée de
tout de toute aspect militaire est-ce
que ça c'est effectivement une solution
ce qui est évident c'est que c'est à
partir du moment c'est vrai que le fait
que cette présence militaire à ce niveau
là ça servait un peu du cash misère une
présence française globalement
déshérence c'est vrai que il faut
[Musique]
et vous décrypter la politique africaine
de Macron alors Macron il est comme
beaucoup de président qu'ils l'ont
précédé il a dit il voulait tourner une
page est-ce qu'il l'a vraiment tourné
cette page de la politique française en
Afrique merci lui et manuel Macron il
est arrivé il était voir les jeunes
Burkina Faso samedi
ou franchement il a voulu tirer
l'ardoise magique en disant je suis
jeune comme vous on va pas s'occuper de
passer on replie les rétroviseurs on
regarde devant etc sauf que le passé ne
passe pas encore dit ça et à ce moment
il y a un peu le retour alors le retour
de l'inconscient le retour de
ressentiment retour d'une période
historique un certain moment donné
Emmanuel Macron a compris que il fallait
quand même faire quelque chose donc il y
a eu des rapports mémorial sur le Rwanda
il y a eu un rapport sur l'Algérie il y
a le rapport maintenant sur le Cameroun
il a compris que voilà alors il dit
voilà je confie le passé aux historiens
mais simplement ça fonctionne pas comme
ça que ça veut dire la politique est
tout à fait toujours au cœur je veux
dire de cette présence française en
Afrique et les jeunes ils ont envie de
parler de cette période ils ont envie de
se parler pas forcément la période de la
colonisation mais de cette période post
coloniale quand vous avez un certain
nombre de chefs d'État qui sont encore
au pouvoir et qui ont été au pouvoir
depuis et installer souvent par la
France depuis ces années
depuis 30 40 ans etc j'ai les fils d'eux
aussi
donc à partir de ce moment-là eux ils
ont envie qu'on parle de cette période
il dit ben attendez les présidents qui
sont là ce sont les fils des gens que
vous aviez installé il y a 30 ans
parlons-en pourquoi ils sont en temps là
est-ce que vous continuez ou pas les
soutenir quel est votre attitude à leur
égard ils ont envie de parler de ça et
on peut pas dire oui on va s'occuper que
digital on va s'occuper que de que de
comme de culture etc ils ont envie de
parler politique les relations sauf que
l'Afrique est totalement mondialisé et
du coup la position de la France qui
fait plus que 4% de part de marché par
rapport à la Chine qui fait 18% et les
propres partenaires maintenant même on
parle pas peu de la Turquie mais qui est
extrêmement active et présente je dirais
à partir de ce moment-là même Emmanuel
Macron on l'a bien vu il est allé quand
il fait ses voyages il va à Canosa
maintenant quand il va au Cameroun tous
les pays d'Afrique centrale qu'il avait
boudé au cours de son premier mandat
maintenant il va mais il va à Cannes ça
je veux dire voir Paul Biya voir Denis
sassou-niguisson au Congo de voir Ali
Bongo au Gabon il va que ça parce qu'ils
avaient boudé ces pays en disant sortons
de la France Afrique on valait que dans
les pays anglophones et l'usage
justement sauf que bah ça fonctionne pas
il nous attendent pas alors justement il
est allé et ça c'est pas une première
mais c'est quand même si il a beaucoup
souligné ça alors il est allé au Nigeria
il est allé au Kenya comme si il se
tournait vers les pays qui
économiquement en Afrique sont forts en
se disant bon ben finalement la relation
que la France doit entretenir avec
l'Afrique c'est une relation qui doit
passer par le commerce par l'économie
parce que sur le reste ben on est un peu
on est un peu marginalisé est-ce que ça
marche ça non parce que on peut pas
faire les fameuses phases sur la proie
et l'ombre et autres mais je veux dire
on voit bien que c'est vrai que Manuel
Macron il a dit pour sortir du prêt
carré on va entraîner les entreprises
françaises tout le business français
vers les pays anglophones et
l’usophophone et sauf que bien
évidemment Mozambique
portugaise et c'est vrai que ancienne
connue portugaise mais c'est vrai que
quand vous aviez vécu dans une rente
politique même pour le business français
vous étiez chez vous en Afrique pendant
des années des années les tous les les
entreprises très souvent les contrats ça
se faisait en téléphonant président et
autres vous passez pas comme ça d'un
business français qui est aussi qui a
ses problèmes de responsabilité aussi de
r.e.s ou autre ça veut dire au niveau
responsabilité sociale et autres c'est
vrai que les jeunes cadres peuvent quand
vous vous affrontiez à des pays comme la
Chine la Turquie ou autre sont pas trop
regardant sur tout ce qui peut être la
corruption dans les pays et autres c'est
vrai que maintenant il y a le business
français en Afrique et pas forcément
adapté
aux situations
pour se battre alors Antoine Glaser
c'est quoi le modèle chinois par exemple
en Afrique comment il s'y prennent ah
bah les modes chinois c'est très simple
moi j'ai vu ça à un moment donné dans
une construction au Gabon ça veut dire
ils disent d'abord oui on va prendre des
employés gabonais et puis ministre
gabonais qui me dit off vous savez on a
essayé de mettre un certain nombre de
d'employés gabonais le matin mais ils
ont pas ils ont pas fait la journée et
puis vous voyez ils font tout de A à Z
et en plus il le filet chinois font tout
de A à Z ils font tout de A à Z et ils
font venir la main d'oeuvre
du mal placé pour ça bien évidemment que
les Chinois les chinois ils vous mettent
des routes comme si des routes comme ça
ils aimaient non mais c'est pas à vous
ça veut dire il faut arrêter
l'infantilisation de l'Afrique il se
démerde c'est dur à dire mais c'est
démerdez-vous il se débrouilleront c'est
leur problème c'est leur problème c'est
pas le problème de la Provin faut
arrêter avec ça elles sont où les forces
de l'Afrique aujourd'hui
par exemple les forces de l'Afrique
c'est la démographie il y a une énergie
qui suit en plus ancien parce que ça
fait qu'un son sympa et disent pas les
vieux mais qui c'est un ancien vous
rentrez ici il manque enfin vous quand
vous rentrez en France vous on sent le
manque d'hébergement
d'un continent c'est des grands marchés
d'Adjamé où j'ai failli mourir étouffer
tellement c'est il y a une pression il y
a un million d'habitants dans un
quartier d'Abidjan est-ce qu'autant avec
le l'ensemble du Gabon mais vous avez
une pression évidemment démographique
importante mais c'est leur problème ils
se
il se débrouille mais il y a une énergie
faramineuse et néanmoins il y a quand
même un truc qui est terrible pour eux
c'est cette exil c'est migrations et qui
ne touchent pas les plus pauvres
d'ailleurs qui sont souvent les gens qui
ont les moyens de partir et ça la fric
se vide aussi quand même de ses forces
vives d'une certaine façon bien sûr mais
encore une fois il faut on peut pas mal
gamer moi ça m'a toujours fait rire par
un bandit toujours oui on va faire les
leçons Niger en disant oui il y a cet
enfant par femme etc sauf qu'il y a pas
de Nigériens en France il fait appeler
un copain exprès à l'ambassade il me dit
pas plus de 14000 15000 nigériens je
parle pas nigériens
de la Francophonie il y en a pas par
contre vous avez peut-être 300 400 000
Maliens mais vous avez pas de Nigériens
donc faut voir selon les pays faut pas
tout amalgamer ça n'a rien à voir je
suis beaucoup de Nigériens vous les
retrouvez en train de faire un certain
nombre de travaux
d'utilité publique comme on dit dans des
pays comme le Gabon ou des pays du Golf
de Guinée qui sont plus riches très très
grosse migration interne bien évidemment
les gens n'imaginent pas que l'ego c'est
c'est 20 millions d'habitants il y a il
y a des dynamismes et des trucs qu'on ne
maîtrise pas et on fait toujours des
clichés à partir de Paris et il y a
aussi la culture africaine qui commence
aujourd'hui à avoir un rayonnement
énorme dans des domaines d'ailleurs qui
sont très diverses parce que dans
continent de leur réalité moralité il y
a plein d'écrivains la mode aussi la
mode
la cuisine enfin c'est infuse toute je
dirais que l'africanité une certaine
façon infuse toute la culture
internationale c'est la mondialisation
ça c'est un mondialisation et puis c'est
ce que je dis à apprendre de l'Afrique
je veux dire c'est vrai on parle
toujours des peintres on voit bien bien
maintenant comme un dans tous les
domaines de la culture il y a vraiment à
apprendre énormément de l'Afrique on
voit que vous allez avoir quand même si
c'est aux États-Unis que ça s'est passé
quand vous avez Bastia avec varol qui
vont faire une expo à Paris et ah mais
c'est c'est l'Afrique et c'est à ce
moment-là c'est là où il faut apprendre
de l'Afrique et cette culture là est
extrêmement importante au niveau c'est
ça qui peut aussi revivifier à travers
un certain nombre de diaspora ici qui
ont la plupart du temps qui considèrent
que dans les postes le responsabilité en
France dans les entreprises il y a
encore un plafond de verre pour eux mais
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux il y
en a justement par contre sur la culture
sur la musique et autres mais faut pas
non plus il faut pas que ça soit un
prétexte pour cantonner l'Afrique
toujours à la sport et à la musique et
donc faut pas oublier ce plafond de
verre pour l'ensemble d'un certain
nombre de gens qui sont français comme
nous mais qui n'ont pas accès à un
certain nombre de postes de
responsabilité il y avait une figure que
vous retiendriez qui qui symbolise qui
incarne l'Afrique pour vous ça serait
laquelle il y a pour les pour les jeunes
c'est Thomas Sankara
complètement inévitable parce que
c'était pas simplement la révolution
c'était il y avait d'une une volonté de
de se ré africaniser ça veut dire soit
les vêtements la nourriture etc vous
intègre ça veut dire pays mais surtout
valoriser absolument le continent
africain et puis il y a Houphouët-Boigny
qui est pour moi vous faites boigner de
vieilles vieux président pourquoi parce
que contrairement à ce qu'on pense j'y
irait son Afrique de jour avec un centre
de gouverneur qui est plutôt d'ailleurs
des des antillaises il gérait la
modernité entre guillemets avec la
France mais il mangeait africain il
gérait la nuit il avait son Afrique de
jour avec les Français il avait son
Afrique de nuit avec les Africains donc
c'est vraiment c'est une image très
forte j'ai connu comme ça un de ses
conseillers qui m'avait dit il
m'envoyait au Burkina Faso que tu es
ancien le volta apporté de l'argent à
des monnaies au Moro Naba qui est le
chef des mossie du coin et puis je
rentrais avec des poulets avec qui
lesquels il faisait des sacrifices et
tout ça c'est l'Afrique de jour en
Afrique de nuit merci Antoine gazer
[Musique]